flights in and out of Britain's second
busiest airport are suspended after
drones were spotted flying in the area
this is what Gail is so worried about
many thousand passengers are affected by
the delays and cancellations at Gatwick
Airport now that includes four thousand
who are stuck at airports unable to
depart or arrive and about six thousand
passengers who were on flights that were
diverted Roxana Saberi is at Gatwick
Airport south of London Roxana good
morning good morning police are still
hunting for the drone operators at this
Airport deals with a major disruption as
you mentioned this is the country's
second busiest airport it was expecting
a record number of passengers come here
over Christmas just today 760 flights
through Gatwick Airport have been
canceled or delayed some of those
flights are heading to big American
airports like Los Angeles in New York
Airport officials say the shutdown
started around 9:00 last night
after two drones were spotted flying
over the airfield the runway reopened
about six hours later but closed again
after 45 minutes following another
sighting of drones the airport's chief
operating officer says it's a quote
deliberate act but officials can't shoot
down the drone because of the danger of
stray bullets flying a drone near an
airport here is illegal and punishable
by up to five years in prison police do
not think this incident is terror
related but we do know that terror
groups have threatened to use drones as
weapons in the past something that
aviation and security officials have
long feared happening at airports around
the world
Gail yep I worry about it too thank you
Roxana Saberi reporting from London's
Gatwick Airport